[Musique]
c'est quoi la différence entre faire
faillite et faire une proposition de
consommateur inflation tentation vous
êtes submergé de dettes et vous lancez
un SOS dans la plupart des cas on vous
lancera deux bouées mais vous ne devrez
en choisir qu'une seule si vous vous
accrochez à celle de la faillite vous
devrez céder vos biens et cela peut
inclure la maison si vous en avez une
presque tout sera vendu pour rembourser
le plus possible vos créanciers pendant
deux ans si vous gagnez plus d'argent
avez un héritage ou gagner le gros lot
ce sera aussi englouti par la faillite
en échange vos dettes de cartes de
crédit de marge de crédit vos factures
en retard vos dettes d'impôt seront
effacées mais 70% des naufragés
financiers s'agrippent plutôt à la
proposition de consommateurs souvent
pour pouvoir garder leur maison parce
que cette bouée vous permettra aussi de
sauver vos biens vous n'aurez pas à les
céder par contre vos dettes ne seront
pas effacées elles seront plutôt
négociées à la baisse par un syndic Vous
aurez ensuite jusqu'à 5 ans pour les
rembourser sans et si jamais vous
obtenez une rentrée d'argent imprévu
vous pourrez la conserver finalement
avant d’atteindre le fond sachez que le
premier appel à l'aide à un syndic en
insolvabilité et souvent gratuite passer
le mot
[Musique]